in 2016 Toronto spent 31 million dollars
to fend off a raccoon invasion the
masked critters were everywhere pooping
on porches stopping traffic and
infesting attics
and they're not just taking over Toronto
reports of raccoon vandalism have
plagued cities like Portland Chicago in
New York City and as raccoon ridden
cities no we can't seem to stop them
between the 1930s and 1980s the u.s.
raccoon population increased 20 fold and
it's still going strong from 2014 to
2015
raccoon complaints in Brooklyn nearly
doubled so how are these masked bandits
making it in big cities well for
starters they can digest just about
anything from fish and acorns in the
forest to dog food and pizza on the
street and just like humans
raccoons we usually prefer the pizza
which is why they flock from woodland to
city in the first place
in Brooklyn for example captured raccoon
sometimes get relocated to Prospect Park
and nearby forests but wildlife
biologists report they often head right
back to the dumpster pack city streets
it's just about impossible to stop them
as Toronto discovered after it's spent
millions on raccoon proof waste bins
unlike traditional bins the lids had
special gravity locks which opened when
a garbage truck armed turns the bin
upside down the idea was that if you cut
off their major food source they would
skip town
but that didn't happen in fact one year
later a wildlife control business
reported that Raccoon related work had
doubled finally a clever raccoon was
caught on camera jailbreaking the new
bin how did she L wit an entire city
well study after study has revealed that
raccoons are considerably smarter than
your average medium-sized critter turns
out raccoon brains have more neurons
packed into their brains than other
animals of the same size in fact they
have the same neuron density as primates
who are notoriously smart and they're
clever brains help explain why raccoons
can open complex locks solve puzzles
with ease and even come up with
solutions to problems that scientists
didn't think of add to that they're
ultra sensitive hands earth paws which
have four times as many sensory
receptors as their feet this helps them
to feel subtle textures like special
trashcan lids in Toronto and even open
locks without looking and unfortunately
for us driving them away is a fool's
errand studies show that after mass
removal populations tend to rebound to
their previous levels in a year after
all females can start giving birth at
just one year old and can have as many
as eight kits in a single year this
quick breeding is also why experts say
mass cullings aren't a long-term
solution and while they're awfully cute
the damage they can cause is not when
raccoons nest in buildings they can
destroy insulation chew up wires and
tear holes through walls and it can cost
you hundreds or even thousands of
dollars to repair that kind of damage
one raccoon was even caught destroying
over three thousand dollars worth of
artwork and just removing them can cost
three hundred to five hundred dollars a
pop plus the
they leave behind can contain roundworms
and other parasites which can enter your
lungs when you breathe or get tracked it
to your home by your pets even worse
raccoons can transmit diseases like
canine distemper and in rare cases
rabies so it's understandable that
cities are trying to find some way any
way to manage them can't do a thing
about it just chase them off they come
back if nothing else it's a lesson
learned we may have built the cities but
we don't necessarily rule them